before they only had one lead the rent
toss the rack gets a good look and now's
the people
Elliott goes to Duran touches it becomes
it down this matchu at first it's trying
to push off a mate a little tired right
now
Durant sighs hard right at camp at home
so much for the entire chance for a
three-point play that stood between
right there Laura is picking up the pace
Durant will stutter dribble lap is good
and lawyers have their first lead of the
second half
the key was start of the second half
play the first six minutes and hasn't
been back since in your life five burkas
played so well figure the buckets are
welcome makes it look easy again than
Golden State
[Applause]
it's a four-point goal instinctly driven
the red drives on Hanalei goes down a
lane running land scoring easily once
again a dominant Duran here in the
fourth quarter it's a six-point lead
[Music]
Durant wants to go one-on-one against
Dotson
[Applause]
can't miss to up by six early actual
airtime it just didn't make the upper
defense and we could get out on the
shooter Durant pulled back long way
the latest defended to try and stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whether it's a 20-point game